it's
like first simul is on the
elbow you have to make that elbow corner
like you're not just shoving it
back there's a place where it's just
light and it works little light and
works second one's on the shoulder don't
come in the elbow it's going to wrap
around you you see the corner drop is on
the
shoulder and you don't do anything he he
hits it
okay so on the
shoulder when you brought the hand
in and out there's the Tilt and then
this corn what I
hit
by just staying still grounding his
energy ground Ving hook
you you see that so you're not you're
not here trying to throw it's going to
wrap around on the second one is on the
hand so from here just
drop
[Music]
so we have hand corner elbow Corner
shoulder corner sumio to let